remember that whole story
about
her emails
her being hillary clinton's emails i'm
sure you can remember
hillary the story went in 2016
was so irresponsible by her use of a
private email server that she should not
be president and instead it should be
donald trump in fact they would chant
lock her up over her emails michael
flynn led a chant
endless chance lock her up lock her up
lock her up
uh but instead
it is actually donald trump
whose administration was riddled with
primative private email servers
encrypted messaging apps pers private
email accounts messaging apps and the
like
the whole story
of trump will be responsible with
information trump will be responsible
with emails trump will do it all the
right way
have records for everything presidential
records act it was bs
and we know that ivanka and jared were
using personal email for business
related to their roles as advisers to
donald trump but now there's an even
bigger
bombshell revelation on this exact issue
we have now learned that donald trump's
last and final chief of staff he had a
few his last and final chief of staff
was mark meadows mark meadows used here
we go
his own personal cell phone for white
house business
one personal gmail account
a second personal gmail account and the
encrypted messaging app signal
all
for official
white house business
these people are pathetic
and they're liars
but they win by doing this stuff and
i'll get to that in a moment this is all
coming out now along with the powerpoint
planning the trump coup which we talked
about yesterday thanks to a 51-page
report from the house select committee
investigating the january 6 riots in
looking at whether to hold mark meadows
in contempt the house put out a report
detailing his different actions and this
includes the revelation that meadows was
using signal
the app
his personal mobile phone and two
personal gmail accounts for white house
business
government officials are supposed to use
government government-issued accounts
and services to communicate about their
work they're supposed to forward private
messages to government accounts to have
transparency and accountability and to
create a record
trump bragged about he would have the
most transparent administration in
history and meadows didn't do it meadows
is not the only one remember that this
was the reason trump said don't vote for
hillary in 2016. but melania trump used
private email
uh ivanka trump did it it's a very very
long list of people and yet nobody's
chanting lock him up
lock her up about the trump family and
staff who did this exact same thing
i haven't heard trumpists demanding mark
meadows be imprisoned
as a result of this
they are nowhere because they don't
actually care about this when a
republican does it and this is one of
the reasons they win that's the
important thing the hypocrisy is not new
i doubt many of you are shocked to hear
that mark meadows was doing this and of
course they are hypocrites we knew that
that's not surprising
but another reason they win
is that they do this stuff
brazenly
they bend the rules on voting
they bend the rules on everything they
can they'll write new rules they'll
throw rules out they'll get rules
canceled they'll attack their opponents
on any basis they can
and when it comes to them
they ignore it all they ignore their
values they don't apologize they don't
even justify it to their voters and
that's why they win they don't even go
into the position of justifying it to
their voters they just ignore it
everything and is ignored and they just
power through and they don't care about
being exposed as hypocrites democrats on
the other hand and i get it because
i don't want to be called a hypocrite i
don't want to be a hypocrite democrats
actually try to avoid being hypocrites
and when they are
they address it even if it's to say it's
defensible for whatever reason
republicans don't do that so democrats
ultimately find themselves in positions
where the only way to proceed is
look like hypocrites and cop to it or
play just as dirty as republicans in
some way shape or form understand that
republicans wanted to jail hillary for
this
and tons of people were doing the exact
same thing in donald trump staff and
they don't even pretend to apologize for
it or write it off as different they
just plow through and it's part of why
they continue to win
uh how democrats deal with that i don't
know because as i've said before
redistricting to pick something
for a while
redistricting is going to be done in a
partisan way republicans will use it to
their advantage when they have an
opportunity to gerrymander democrats
have to do the same we have to change
the system but democrats have to do the
same while that's the system
this other type of stuff demanding
people be extra judiciously locked up
when they haven't even been accused of a
crime because of the revelation that
they use private email or whatever
i get it we don't want to stoop to their
level their level is disgusting so what
do you do to win i don't know the answer
i don't know the answer but this is a
perfect perfect example of how
republicans are throwing very heavy
stones from weak glass houses and yet
nobody throws any stones back i don't
know what the answer is but i'm curious
to hear from you
we are almost at the end of the year
it's it's shocking actually that 2021 is
already almost over
we want to start off 2022
the it's an election year and the
election is going to start i think quite
early
we want to start off with a bang of
sorts as i've told you we've seen a
decline in membership over the last four
months of the year a lot of people
struggling financially etc
on january 1st we are going to do a
midterm 2022
kick off the year
with a bang membership blowout like
nothing that has ever happened before
you know how trump says it should never
be allowed to happen again well
our accountant and lawyer are telling me
already
whatever you're doing on january 1st
don't do it again because it's going to
be crazy but we are going to do a wild
membership discount on january 1st i
want to start off strong i would love
for you to get a membership on january
1st you want to be notified of how to
take advantage of the
insane immoral discount we're going to
be offering just get on my mailing list
at joinpakman.com
and on january 1st you'll get an email
from me telling you exactly what to do
to take advantage of this
it's it's crazy hopefully the irs has no
rules against outrageous membership
discounts because if they did we'd be
screwed we'd be heading to audit central
let me put it that way or arden as trump
likes to call them
get on my newsletter davidpakman.com and
you'll be notified january 1st
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time
they have some great advantages when you
look closely at a kamikoto knife you see
the quality of the iron work they only
use japanese steel every knife comes in
a perfect heavy duty ash wood box makes
storage really easy it looks great in
your kitchen or drawer the balance of
the knives is just amazing i've been
using them for everything every knife
comes with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikoto and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you fifty dollars off
on top of their other special offers
just go to camikoto.com
pacman and use the code pacman for fifty
dollars off the link is down below